[Musique]
bonsoir mesdames ou bonsoir monsieur ce
que vous venez vous soyez dans la démo
ici c'est un petit exercice de
calligraphie auquel je me livre avant
d'entamer mes yeux et la calligraphie
c'est un art qui m'a permis de me
découvrir c'est un art qui m'a permis de
me révéler avant même avant de découvrir
les autres alors c'est un écrivain les
mots c'est en écrivant le texte
c'est en les croisant ou en fait détaler
g depuis l'école primaire et jusqu'au
collège que la passion de la
calligraphie resté ancré en moi et ça a
été la porte d'entrée pour les arts
plastiques plus tard vous savez dans les
arts plastiques il y en a qui arrivent
par le dessin et après il pratique la
peinture
moi je suis venu aux arts plastiques par
la calligraphie et l'amour de l'écriture
et la manière
la façon d'écrire joliment d'écrire avec
caractère avec agilité avec grâce mais
les mots les signes donc en l'écrasant
j'obtiens souvent des formes et obtient
des personnages et je fais même des
télégrammes
alors dès le bas âge
cette passion je vais développer et puis
jusqu'au collège ou sur les bords du lac
bam
je regardais les femmes travailler à
faire du maraîchage à faire la
mariculture vieux regardais les pilotes
qui est j'étais au loin leur filet pour
prendre le poisson et donc les
silhouettes et puis les formes
flottantes dans l'eau est au bord de
l'eau
ça m'a inspiré et jusqu'aujourd'hui je
porte en moi cette trace de vie et cette
multitude de foule au bord du lac bam
l'aîné sous des formes variées la main
création aujourd'hui parce que l'eau il
faut le dire ries tous nos vies il y a
des en gras sur cette terre où il faut
aller à 2 3 kilomètres pour trouver de
l'eau en suisse que dans certains
endroits il suffit d élever puis
d'ouvrir la tête du robinet fuit l'eau
coule à flot et donc je travaille avec
les encres de chine et j'ai besoin d'eux
pour le faire
je travaille avec l'afrique et j'avais
besoin d'eau pour le faire donc quand je
travaille en parlant des femmes en
parlant des enfants qui vont à des
distances pour prélever l'eau est ce que
l'on est assez importante non seulement
pour moi mon travail mais en même temps
pour ma vie et pau ce qui m'entoure et
donc ces témoignages
j'ai le porte aussi dans des sculptures
que j'ai pu réaliser par la suite
et puis j'ai eu l'occasion de venir à
ouagadougou
parce que je suis né à kong ici est donc
un goût si c'est ma ville natale et le
lac bam pour si ce que je fais et
entrera de plain-pied ben ma carrière
aujourd'hui donc allez-y venu à
l'université faux possible les études en
arts et communication
j'étais loin de m'imaginer que j'allais
vraiment faire de l'athlé grassi mon
métier et ma passion c'est d'une dizaine
bon et la peinture uniquement parce que
moi c'est un genre mineur
maintenant je lève une ruse les garder
en moins et puis il faut le dire
j'ai compris que ce n'est pas seulement
une affaire décrire joliment des mots
mais ils n'avaient d'écrire avec la
grâce des lettres c'est beaucoup plus de
cela parce que je faisais mes skis et
diffuser mes graphiques pouvoir du bal
ait un gain parce que jeanne augier
quand il était étudiant vous avoir
là-bas pas moins les collègues pour
tester donc ça a été pour moi une
opportunité de pouvoir faire les excuses
de pouvoir travailler sur des
personnages des sujets mobiles des
sujets vivants et donc j'ai pu vraiment
à partir des supports à ces nobles comme
le carton fait de dessins faits de
calligraphie et c'est avec ce travail là
qui monte
d'où un mouvement qui monte la ville
en plein air en plein épanouissement
dans les maquis extérieur a donc c'est
le sujet peu traité sur des cartons que
j'ai amené dans les années quatre-vingt
dix-huit pour ma première exposition
personnelle à la fondation ou du jaune à
vos gains alors les matières issues d'un
quarteron lourde car on est à décider et
de les exposer et
voilà où commence mon entrée dans la vie
professionnelle
avec ce carton là sur lesquelles je
consigne et même aux mains du joie
le moment des choix déchets qui m'ont
tous mais aussi les moments difficiles
à tripoli la vie d'étudiant une vie
faite par faire et puis les fins de
formation pour bâtir à l'avenir est ce
qu on trouvera du travail
après bon est ce que je voulais vivre de
ce métier des calligraphes que j'entame
il a donc toutes ces futures et sortent
dans ce bout de carton que j'ai réalisé
et est donc vous moi le vaudois va donc
au delà nous sommes en fait de dessiner
des joueurs qui plaisent mais en même
temps ça va dans les tréfonds de l'âme
fava au fond de nous-mêmes pour révéler
souvent
notre douleur notre évolution assez fort
et c'est en cela que ça peut vraiment
avoir une résonance sociale juillet et
donc j'ai eu la chance d'exposer ses
heures à la fondation hollywood en 98
des filles
la une qui a vraiment retenu mon
attention
c'était trouble et passion n'oublie pas
e
cette union après bien vu c'est qu'ils
ont vu à l'époque mondiale sauf les
bleus sont à ses formes c'est pas il ne
assez joli mais s'arrêtera c'est
vraiment quelque chose en moi les
épisodes difficiles de ma vie et j'y
disais ah c'est qu'ils se moquaient des
couleurs assez difficile qu'il y ait
choisi s'exprime en fait il a visé et
les jeux pour voir les yeux les brevets
sont celles demandées de tous les
combats et à la femme à l'être aimé
pourquoi je ne sais pas vous mais moi
lettre la personne de la famille qui
j'aime le plus c'est elle qui me l'a dit
et voilà et c'est pour ça que oui oui
c'est vrai et donc sur les passions
quand je l'aï exposé à honorine à 98 et
il ya un couple de français qui arrivait
au bout qu'il a pour la première fois et
qui est tombé vraiment sous les charmes
de l'île il voulait l'acheter et donc
ils ont essayé de discuter pour
marchander mais les galeristes n'était
pas d'accord il m'a fait venir ou me
demander mon opinion je lui dis il est
17 avec une signification particulière
pour eux je ne pourrais pas d'un
convivial
j'étais content quand même cet homme là
puisse trouver à trouver quelqu un ou
deux personnes qui leur donnerait me
signification particulière plutôt que
d'aller découvrir bull au 21e dégâts
mais les gars est l'égalité vraie face à
de cette façon et il a dit non non on va
attendre un peu et donc les couples qui
voulaient durant question est répartie
et tu vas promis de revenir le lendemain
le lendemain il a really 10 et 1
intercités
ouah ouah en état tout gêné
et leur a promis de tout faire pour que
les galets lisses le dal de 24 qui ai
compris que bon il y avait plus rien à
faire et j'ai papier à la main dont l'un
des skis ski ont servi de préparation
les croquis faits de la part de l'armée
les pièges avec quelques gilet rayé gris
un guide des princes aux nations
alors ils ont pris donc ses cadeaux dans
les métiers et c'était bon c'est être
dans la série d'une évasion jeu c'est
vrai que c'était avec la ve république
d'intensité et la première ronde
et puis pour comme si de rien n'était
la vie continuait son goût fils la
calligraphie et puis un beau jour ma
tante qui m'a élevé ne fit appel au
final petit carré où elle a appris
qu'elle a in utero les deux géants de
papier ciré devenir mais ce prix
international jeudi voix
à sa famille démunie un esprit mais ce
que je fais début à la fin il est un
petit comité des deux femmes qui sont là
qui vivent à l'egypte a fait de
l'éducation et des données ce que boire
pour moi qui allait devenir un médecin
journaliste qui dit non mais voir
escrocs je ne sais pas mais ces dessins
ça des gens que je vois
la police n'a jamais arrêté pour cela la
gendarmerie non plus et puis il vient de
se voir la prison de voir la sécurité
donc je passe quand même c'est un
travail tous les lundis accepté et puis
je propose un prix c'est pas vous
marchez les jeunes ils les gaffes
s'ils sont intéressés ils achètent ils
t'ont pas un réservoir et c'était comme
ça et du bon et
et si j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous
on va à 8 et enfin le pool exposé où on
travaille à voir ça va jusqu'à
l'avènement de dire oui je vais ramener
la smala gbagbo voilà savall avatar sera
pas d'aller déjà de l'avant donc bon et
après effectivement j'ai eu dix ans plus
tard après toulouse j'ai eu mon
exposition ma première exposition
personnelle la richesse et la lega donc
je me l'a accusé et puis la gallery
s'appelle tel-aviv à tel-aviv à le salir
il ya un fou qui cherchent à 3 avant le
vernissage qui dit bon mais je ne
connais personne dans le gard ici c'est
la première fois que je viendrais pour
l'exposition libon mais ils n'ont pas
voulu dire encore plus donner plus de
détails
c'est un peu
j'aime l'art au rendez-vous à lévitation
et puis c'était bien j'avais rencontré
madame lizin plutôt bienvenu pour voir
mon exposition dit voilà il était
content de voir que mon travail a pu
mener jusqu'à chez eux
et puis bon j'aime moi j'ai mis ces
croquis et esquisses préparatoires sans
vraiment géré savoir la suite la
résonance que ça allait à vabre après
dans la vie de ces personnes
moi c'était fin dans un cadre intimiste
du fil dans mon atelier sur de
véritables avec ou en juillet ma purée
puis est pas la même couleur un peu
d'eau et ça se limite à celle des ports
intégristes comme ça mais je ne savais
pas que ça pouvait les jaillit autour de
moi et susciter un peu par des patients
ou alors toucher à des sensibilités à
quelques milliers de kilomètres et donc
on rencontre ces poule à
et les charges etc n'ont rien dit de
leur vie mais j'ai vu quand même
comprendre que leur a beaucoup compté où
et quand je leur ai fait ce cadeau là
et puis il ya les vient au burkina après
la fin de l'exposition
et la dame chez qui secoue la loger
m'a invité chez elle et on me dit
vraiment merci christophe
pour ses gestes pleins d'amis ticket tu
as fait à l'égard de mes parents parce
que c'était sa famille dit elle et sa
famille et j'ai dit non mais j'ai fait
un cadeau sada des dix ans un feeling et
ça peut pas continuer lino les passages
il y à peu les dessins et dialysés
trouvent les patients ça une importance
particulière pour ses deux personnes
qu'il rencontre et ils ont été interné
dans un hôpital psychiatrique et ils ont
traversé des moments difficiles et ils
se sont rendus dans cet internat et
c'est pour ça que ça a beaucoup compté
pour moi
vraiment j'ai fait je ne me sers moi
parce que je me disais c'est l
expression des sentiments étudiant veut
pas comprendre que d'autres allaient
elle et sentir
je vous la dirai tout à des émotions ou
alors que ça allait toucher à une vie
aussi intensément
alors ce que je voulais dire pour
terminer c'est que et nous ne savons pas
où nos passions peuvent nous conduire
mais je sais que quand elles vont nous
conduire loin et je serai toujours dans
le bon sens et que ça nous rapproche
fléché qu'on connaît et sait qu'on ne
connaît pas et voulait merci